jesus loves me yes I know for the Bible
tells me so welcome to another episode
of Tiger belly I am wonderful I am
wonderful and I am I am the Bobby Lee we
got kalila we got Gil Gil we got dick
dick George has a pink dick and let me
just say someone that I love to start
off with fun facts because elephants
isn't that not true
a tiger belly fun I love fun facts so
here's a fun fact for you the Chicago
Cubs has not won the World Series since
1908 which is the last time George got
laid I was like there's a fun fact he's
given a real yeah there's the photo back
for you I also would like to talk about
up front
Jessica's birthday party Saturday was a
fun yeah the fun for you George really
so George shows up at this uh I like
he's telling sorry but he wasn't there
that wasn't there but I'm gonna tell the
story
George shows up the party and Jessica
was holding hands with under the guy and
then George left the party earlier
that's what I had heard that true did
you feel jealous though when you saw
Jessica holding another guy's at hand
you swore to God look at me right now
you're lying
white dude don't ever [ __ ] lie to me
again my friend why I can see right
through your [ __ ] white dude eyes
okay look at me right now don't ever
[ __ ] lie to me I love you dude all
right and we're friends and we're all
friends here
we don't lie okay I thought we lied to
women we do like to win but there's no
winning or you know losing in this
situation with you and the and the girl
I feel bad and that's bad on Jessica why
is it bad on her because she knows that
George has a crush mm-hmm you know that
George you know he said he had yeah
really crushes live and Dyke that
quickly yeah I don't know because I've
had I've been on crushes they last for
years especially when you get rejected I
should have had you crushed on
longer like much longer I crush on you
no babe no you you've ever said to me
like I'm actually kind of like smiling
really hard you so [ __ ] much that's
the sweetest thing I've ever I love you
so much and you just mentioned to me
that you had other options on tinder
you just say that before we start I also
remember saying that we cannot talk
about it on the podcast yeah yeah so
you'd match with Tito Ortiz let's just
get it out there so she tells me that
she matches with Tito Ortiz and she he
invited her to hang up Christmas lights
weird thing to do which is very strange
such a good move
that's a good move like because it's
like it's in a city in a way of like
like hey it's Lord the Lord's birthday
come to my house we're gonna do
something innocent have fun yeah and
then what you're hanging Christmas
lights he pulls out his [ __ ] dick and
slams it right in your boat what if it
wasn't even really him like what it was
a what if it was a fake account it's not
because you know first of all you
already know like you you were you were
gonna do what you did to me to him which
in a coffee shop
I never met him number one he's but if
you were gonna do it you would pop up as
well tell you which other people I match
Devin bender no god I wish oh geez I
wouldn't be here right now oh if it's
babies no you wouldn't have been you
would have [ __ ] you want and then left
to you no no no no I would have trapped
his ass trap life trash bag really sure
yeah boy we have [ __ ] turkey-basted
myself with his [ __ ] sperm which oh
that really is that's hurtful because we
kill two babies you know so that's a lot
and also fYI to you all of you I'm
wearing a turtleneck and I'm sorry I
look [ __ ] legit it does look good I
look really good good man but on now too
and I'm gonna say this also that when I
was in San Francisco this weekend I got
six turtlenecks shout out to from Tiger
fat-bellied fans one dude threw it on
stage allowance on stage don't do that
don't do that and also I want to also
reiterate that
Tiger belly fans you don't have to
heckle during the show you know in the
middle of a punchline please don't yell
out George as a pink dick
please don't Leah louts TB we be you
know it's it's it's hard
[Music]